together we are
strong attackers incoming in 30
seconds for comat
manuvers
5 4 3 2 1 attackers incoming defend
objective
a get in there
carry ahead
break you're
cover
just a
scratch
Qui around on
point barri is on you
go
B
body
you're
cover ready for
batt Give Me Your Best
Shot barri is on you go turet
eliminated
ready onwards to
Victory our enemies
return are going for
the gravity
killed
Justice rains from
above
destroyed I am still in the
fight we need to defend the
objective objective
lost new defense Point get in
there guess it's
Bring
It
Go Give Me Your Best
Shot
your
cover ready for
Buble turret FES in our
way get in there
staring
up
brity to Victory ready for battle let's
be anyone else get on the objective we
cannot let it fall into their
hands give me your
F turret
eliminated get in
there
kill work together push them
back bring
it
let maximum
charge
defensive point strike as one bar is on
you
go
back
from onwards to
Victory
a get get in
there that's more like
it ready
for
got
go don't R back
body
for
for bring it you're
cover ready for battle be K
me
gold Give Me Your Best
Shot gravity
k your cover
die for
the ready
for is that all you've
got bar on
go
turet
eliminated go they're taking the
objective concentrate our
defenses 60 seconds
remaining getting in
there clear
the Justice rains from above
come on everyone on the point just like
in
dream back gravity
kill
victory
play of the
game I
am
Hal